[Music]
you've most likely seen my guests on the
hit web series atop the fourth wall were
bad comics bird he goes under the name
Linkara and he rips apart bad comics old
and new and also comes across quite a
few adventures while doing so he has a
robotic sidekick a magic gun a giant
spaceship and a sassy old lady nobody
seems to understand they infect grandma
he starred in the channel awesome
anniversary movies kickassia suburban
nights into boldly flee and if I got any
of that continuity wrong at all I'm sure
he'll let me know please welcome Lois
love hog how are you sir I'm doing just
fine
but to correct you right off the bat go
ahead Braddock bring back grandma is not
really my character least I don't really
count
I don't really count her as my character
when I ask someone for a cameo I ask you
I don't need ya Haley but the vit yeah
but the thing is I really do count fat
grandma as their character well I'm just
acting out because I would have never in
a million years done fat grandma on my
own you are in fact a vessel for fat
grandma that one day will be passed on
to and of the spirit possesses me that's
how in in the fan are we want to see out
there of her slapping Mussolini that's
that's the thing that ended up on
Twitter people wanted to see fat grandma
slapping Mussolini with sass if nobody
has done that yet somebody somebody get
on that someone did I think one person
did but you know it's always nice to see
dictators get slapped so keep it keep
going keep going with it like they go go
the full range full axis of evil he
named love heart mm-hmm
that must have got you a lot of friends
in school oh god yes that was a fun
elementary school experience you loved
hogs you love hogs
it's Norwegian ah it Asya it's Norwegian
it means leaf hill it means what lethal
house in feel leaves how does it feel to
have a name that not only sounds that
way but carries so much dignity
obviously it does technically I mean I
mean the my first name Lewis means
warrior Lee at least well renowned
warrior in several cultures so basically
I'm the warrior on the hill of leaves so
that works the network
Wow that actually does come together
much better than Lois love Hawk yeah I
think my parents named me after a
Supreme Court justice I can't remember
which one though if I recall correctly
meaning they they told it like years and
years ago it was probably the one thing
was it probably was you're one of the
few people I know who openly
acknowledges that you have a huge ego
you're very very open with that oh god
yes and yet knowing that I know you're a
very cool guy you're open to making fun
yourself and you're wonderful with your
fans where do you feel is the place
where it could lose balance or could
actually benefit you because it seems to
benefit you great it Bennett well I
don't know if the ego itself benefits me
other than just having a lot of
confidence uh but the thing is what
here's what's having me in the past um
back a long time ago well I say a long
time you're like what 10 12 years my god
I feel old you know not uh I wrote self
published novels these horrible fantasy
novels which are still online available
on fans love to torment me by finding
them and buying them and doing readings
of them and and most recently is that
man the second book isn't as good as the
first one because it's not as funny
because I got older and I got better at
writing them but the thing is I was so
proud of that I was so proud of being a
14 year old who had written his own
novel and done so and that just started
inflating the ego right up I did like
two or three more books uh and from
there I just like well you got to keep
this ego trip up I got to promote these
things and tell people about well I I
know exactly what I'm doing I started a
webcomic for a while Lightbringer which
I drew and wrote myself and finally got
some harsh critiques that knocked some
sense into me but the thing is the ego
doesn't tear you very well if you don't
actually have anything to back yourself
up on it and the stuff that I produced
was crap and it was not good crab
meaning the fans liked it because they
like seeing where I was back then and
they get some you know enjoyment factor
out of that for me though it's like a
popular writer like judging Neil Gaiman
his first grade book reports or
something like that of course are going
to be crap compared to where they are
right now so in my case it's it's seeing
this ego trip kind of like smack me back
down and real and realize you know I'm
not as great as I thought I was I got to
build myself back up be more humble and
uh get myself back to a point where I
can justifiably have that ego be more
open with it and somebody who also kind
of acknowledges that he has a big ego
and has feared having that take over me
I think something you sort of mentioned
is that the failure can actually it can
actually make you realize that wow when
I fail it really hurts but when I'm good
I know not to take it too much for
granted and if anything when you do
succeed you feel better and the ego does
sort of allow you to say hey I can do
this but I know I'm not perfect but
still gives you the courage to do it the
other thing that helps out that
especially with the with the fear of
failure and knowing how how glory is
fleeting and all that is seeing
real-life celebrities you know real
celebrities not like internet
celebrities like me you know real
celebrities in the world who have like
tabloid newspapers following them around
I see them destroying themselves in
their own lives and the damage they
caused as because their egos get too
much for them so it's a constant
knocking on the back of my head saying
don't get too full of yourself don't
make the same mistakes others have made
remember this could all go away in a day
just the end don't man don't let
yourself make the same mistakes they do
control what you say control what you do
control the story and don't let yourself
be consumed by your own ego
probably the most obvious question I
could ask why comics because there are
so many other forms of media out there
that people get into and it seems you
start getting into it at a time where
they're certainly known but weren't
weren't as huge as they were now using
to get on just before that really big
peak of the comic book movies and sort
of this return to this comic explosion I
got into comics in the late
90s early 2000s which was several years
after the speculator boom which for
those that those of you at home we don't
know what that is it's when comics were
suddenly being bought up mostly for
collectors value rather than any like
enjoyment out of the story suddenly
comics were popular because well this I
could sell this years from now and I'll
put my kids through college we have like
hollow foil covers and spending this
issue someone dies and this issue
someone dies at number zero and number
one half number point seventy three and
you know just all these special things
that are supposed to be special of
course of everything special nothing is
and that's what happened the reason why
comics like Action Comics number one or
Detective Comics number twenty-seven are
are so expensive these days because
there's not very many copies of them
left and if there's a million copies of
blood gun number 3/4 then and then who
cares you don't need that I got into
comics when around the time when Marvel
was starting to recover from its
bankruptcy DC was doing really well
creatively it was a good time for comic
books because the stories were pretty
much the best they had been in a long
time image had started to shed its own
image of being the company that Rob
Liefeld helped build with lots and lots
of over muscled uh snakes spined women
and suddenly we have like actual stories
being told and this is the great
independent market that you can go to
and you'll have it have a shot about
getting into the bigger industry now why
comics in particular because I love
comics Eila but in particular the thing
about me is I love superhero comics in
particular and there is a distinction
that must be made there most people when
they talk about comic books they're
talking about superheroes because that's
the mainstream if there's one thing that
is considered the American comic book
it's superheroes in general that's what
is overtaking the market and there are
other than their play of other comics
out there from indie publishers you got
your splice and lights you got your
sci-fi you got your fantasy you've got
everything under the Sun but the only
ones that sell in any great numbers are
superhero stuff at least in the USA in
Japan where manga is
popular all over the place they have all
Chandra's are pretty much popular across
the board european comics especially
england has 2000 ad usually focusing on
like sci-fi stuff and and all that fun
stuff french is all over the place and I
keep just getting away from why comics
so why comics
I love superheroes I love the heroic
code to them I see them as modern-day
mythology I see them as modern-day
knight errant basically being people we
can either relate to or ascribe to be
more like and generally just good people
and in some cases with super with
superhero comics you can do things that
while they can envision them on the big
screen and try to make them reality uh
you need a huge budget to pull that off
where as an artist the only limit is
their imagination and talent with that
said on top the fourth wall and your
webseries you not only do reviews of
comics but you had this continuing story
line we do go on these grand adventures
who have sidekicks you went villain and
this really indicates my point because
there's a lot of things that I
envisioned in my head that aren't gonna
come across on a webseries of the budget
I was going to say is this something
where when you were putting this
together either at the beginning or just
as it went along we said this is sort of
my chance to do kind of a live action
comic book or the closest that I can
probably get away with not at first well
at first it was just really inspired by
the nostalgia critic uh because hack
that hack he was a jerk what an ass I
know it was really inspired by the
nostalgia critic and that style of
reviewing info and and I think the TV
Tropes calls it accentuates the negative
and there was really no market for that
out well there was a market but but no
one had filled it yet and now I
originally started with text reviews
there were webs before video reviewing
became a thing especially with the
advent of the AVGN and ARMA k21 most
people were doing text reviews of movies
and TV shows and in particular
inspirations there were the agony booth
djibouti's movie reviews of b-movie
planets just a bunch of places that were
doing like long
recaps of movies and adding their own
humorous content to it and I was and I
decided well I could try to do this with
comic book because I know I have a good
passing knowledge of comic history and I
could and I know plenty of bad comics
out there so I can start reviewing that
and after a while it was it was fun but
it was time-consuming to write up all
these things and I wasn't getting any
money out of it so they became less
frequent I started off weekly went to
monthly and then once in a blue moon
then I discovered the nostalgia critic
and a whole bunch of video reviewers who
were doing this kind of thing but in
video form and I was inspired to try to
do that so in terms of starting off a
story no it was just
I saw a creative enterprise that could
potentially make money man I didn't
expect to start off and like
get-rich-quick because a lot of people
do a lot from what I hear but I thought
this would be a great way to spread my
creative wings and do and do something
maybe make a little bit of side side
change if I was a little bit popular
because no one was doing comic book
reviews as far as I knew you seem to
come in at a time when as I said before
it was not as huge as it was now with
comic books getting so popular now most
because of the market in films and
making comic book movies have you felt
that at least with superhero comics that
it still kept faithful to being as good
as when you were introduced to them or
do you think there's stuff that can be
fixed
oh god no there's I mean I have this
thing now with the especially with DC in
particular I won't go into the gory
details because that would I would that
would be an hour long interview where
I'm just ranting and raving DC probably
what this is going to be anyways DC in
particular I have this thing now where
I'm where anytime they make some they do
some bizarre creative choice or bizarre
business decision I just post this like
image from the West Wing where president
Bartlet tells Josh true-or-false my life
would be better right now if we've
created jobs why is it that for every
good thing you do around here we have to
endure three screw-ups and that's really
a DC feels right now I feel like I mean
I'm some asshole on the internet review
bad comic books and there are days when
I feel like I could be doing a better
job and that should not be the case and
DC is making good decisions over here
and then over here it's like they're
hitting themselves three times with a
hammer and then trying to run the
business DPL Marvel is Marvel has has
really overtaken things Marvel has
actually been on top of the community
there's there's like he has official
charge like top ten companies in terms
of sales Marvel has been on top for a
long time DC used to use the top sales
especially in the early 90s and I think
that's why some of the creative
decisions are reflecting that these days
but Marvel has really pulled themselves
out of their bankruptcy that they
experienced in the mid to late 90s and
then they've recovered from that started
selling movie rights the company's
spider-man was successful Blaine was
successful I'll be up loud as I say
blades DC no it's blades Marvel uh we
started seeing much more successful
movie franchises and the DISA and then
they decided to start Marvel Studios and
then we had the Avengers in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and they've done a
bang-up job trying to have the comics
reflect the movies and the movies
reflect the comics as best as they can
and they finally come to realize there
are demographics out there that we
should be trying to appeal to and we
should not make this the all-white male
heterosexual boys club as we right now
we right now at the time this interview
at least we have an all-female x-men
team we have serve a contradiction see
how it is called x-men yeah maybe X
people so or something or just X yeah
but we also have a new Miss Marvel who
is a Muslim teenager we have more women
headlining books more women members of
the Avengers and the defenders we had a
vengers Academy that kind of got screwed
over by Avengers arena but every company
makes mistakes but that's the thing
they're actually recognizing you know
even if we don't entirely get this even
though we don't always we're not gonna
always make this right but you know
let's give it a try at least let's try
to appeal to these let's actually try to
appeal these markets instead of
trying to foster to the same 45 year old
comic fans that other people have been
trying to appeal to who are rapidly
losing interest in this mind you again
there are still mistakes being made
again at the time of this recording
Wolverine is slated to die yeah that'll
stick really he's really gonna stay dead
you know he makes no money Oh gorgeous
yeah it'll put him on on every cover at
all but the death of Wolverine event is
I think I think I don't know oh I
haven't looked into myself but the price
of the book itself is gonna be like five
bucks now bear in mind comics have not
matched with inflation they have not
stuck around because in the early 80s
you could have a book that was still
about fifty to seventy-five cents then
steadily it started to raise up and
priced about a dollar dollar 25 then
early 90s speculator boom comic prices
jumped drastically and they've never
recovered from that and books that would
normally cost $3 they've started to cost
$4 and now they're pushing it to $5 for
roughly the same amount of content and
is there any reason is there no reason
why people are jumping to digital and
rejecting you know the old method of
just the flaw pieces are called and
we're really just the page turning and
alcohol floppies yeah Matt
magazine-style comics because otherwise
because there's a difference in you have
floppies which are the single issues
then you have trade paperbacks which are
collections of like six to ten issues or
so and those and some people have said
well I'm going to stop reading reading
the monthly stuff and just go over the
trades because all the books are written
for the trades anyway there's less
self-contained books out there there's
not something you could just hand you
just an individual comic you can just
hand to someone and get them interested
in it because it's you know part three
of a story or something of a six-part
storyline and the storylines themselves
are not following like a three-act
structure because they've been you're
being stretched out out longer and
longer than they should be they're
written for the trade as they as it's
called now of course you know on about
really bad comics we've seen some of the
words course gotta ask what is the
absolute
worse that you have seen whatever you
reviewed it or not you know it used to
be this comic that that I still want to
remain secret just because I'm still on
the fence about it it was this comic
from image I don't want I still won't
want to say the name of it but it was
really bad it failed in everything and
story and character in artwork in
writing it just was an icky icky book
from start to finish give us a time
period of when it came out 90s I'm
pretty sure 90s if not that early 2000s
but but I'm more and more moving towards
Frank Miller's Holy Terror as the worst
comic book I've ever read the artwork is
atrocious the message is against
everything I believe in
it's very racist or at the very least
even even if you don't owe you want to
say well he doesn't actively say all
Arabs are evil at the very least it's is
very bigoted towards Islamic people at
the very least and equates them all as
terrorists now you and I were and I
reviewed it for my 300th episode I was
gonna say you reviewed a Miller stuff
countless times practically even at the
section called Miller time
just dedicated to making fun of it is it
just him in general and what a crackpot
he can be sometimes what is there ever
this fear that you're going to run into
one of these people you talk bad about
whether it be a Miller or a live elder
or any of those people there's always
that fear but I have little but a little
fear of actually meeting them in person
really I fear more that they're gonna
try to send like a cease and desist
letter against against the videos which
I think I should be probably fine and
just for the legal reasons but at the
same time it's I don't want to like
cause us think cuz some of these people
especially Frank Miller Iike he is crazy
he's great gray he is me but that's
perfect if he comes after you with legal
action he'll be like and this is my
lawyer
I'll cramp and he would just have no but
he's not he's not that kind of crazy
he's the kind of crazy rants about about
conspiracy theories and all that but he
probably has but he still works in
Hollywood so it's possible he has like
legitimate lawyers who do who aren't
crazy and can probably did and
if they wanted to can probably shut down
a video what so but Jess you made crazy
sense yeah which is disappointing me to
be sad but that's that's the worst of it
good that I wasted time working on
something that's the worst that could
probably happened they couldn't shut
down the entire show or something is the
worst is they stopped a video I feel
depressed for a day because I wasted all
that time and then move on with my life
I have little fear of them actually
confronting me in person mostly because
as far as they're concerned I'm just
some asshole on the Internet
the same thing happened with Joe Quesada
and one more day that was the 200th
episode a spider it was a story about
spider-man making a deal with Satan to
erase his marriage that's the abstract
of course of the other story it's much
more boring and stupid than that over
the so of the course of it but uh but
someone tried to send the link to him to
the videos and and he said I don't feel
like reading any any critiques of my
work so clearly he didn't click on them
because he would have known it was a
video and not uh and not our written
thing so because that's the thing a lot
of these creators they have thick skin
they don't care if some jerk gave them
negative reviews and they move on with
their lives
have you ever had a creator of a comic
that was actually thankful or happy of
something you said yeah because on top
of that you're actually in a comic
recently you do comics actually me to
copy
hmm oh yeah I've actually run into
several comic creators uh is issue it's
rarely ever a writer or an artist uh in
this case the ones that always pop out
in my mind I think was an artist who
helped work on Dark Knight strikes again
as like as like a letter or color or
something and that was a case a friend
of a friend had heard uh who had known
it but the more direct one I had was
night cat the cover artist for Knight
cat which was a comic it from the mid
90s of Marvel trying to promote a new
new singing super heroine they had a
tie-in woman who would go around at
conventions and really released an album
to to cut to accompany it it was crap
but the cover artist uh was very was
very likely liked the review because I
was very complimentary to the cover does
the cover was really good was this nice
painted style and he and he used his
actual cats in it just as models in it
but otherwise yeah I've appeared now in
two comics just as a cameo one was a an
issue of a sonic comic uh and and of
course the creators names escape me I
feel very disappointed I'm feel the
shame that I don't remember their names
but I've like had ad minor
communications with them I might do
something with them later on just
because they've offered uh and the other
one was was a larger cameo in my little
littlest petshop because it is I keep
wanting to call it my little pet the
pony for yeah the Willis pet shop which
both the artist and the writer are fans
of my show and they just stuck me as a
background cameo talking with a woman
who has red hair so obscure lupa claims
that it's her uh and just me like I like
smugly like looking Nick comics and they
both sent messages to me let it letting
me know hey you can we draw this and
wheeler a big fans of your show and they
sent me a signed copy of it and as it
that's wonderful that is glorious I love
these I love these people who who know
that I'm that most the time I'm not I'm
usually tried would to avoid attacking
the character of the people
well uh who creates stuff mean I'll call
them I will call them idiots sometimes
but usually I reserve that for people
who just make really boneheaded writing
mistakes that they should know better
about especially if I keep seeing
repeated pattern of their work but
otherwise I try not to attack their
their moral or ethical centers or then
as a person Frank Miller I'll gladly do
because he's a racist homophobic sexist
asshole
now with this show with the type of
fourth wall on all these characters they
play a lot of them any of these
storylines that have the strong
continuity and they continue on um what
made you actually want to go from just
reviewing comics to turning us into this
great big grand epic that always keeps
going cuz you have these very tightly
knit stories that go on and even when we
do something for the adversary's you
check to make sure that you know the
continuity matches that it's not going
to get in the way which even though we
make fun of you like bad for I still
highly respect because I think both of
us have seen uh whatever art form where
the movie or comic whatever where they
clearly don't care or they'll just make
it up and like and get rid dwarfish done
that one yeah but at least with Red
Dwarf that's a comedy it's not meant to
be taken just too seriously you're a
comedy too though hey can you take it
very seriously uh there's definitely the
sense that you try to keep it a very
controlled how did it go from just
reviewing comics to this really long
grand storyline it started out with the
mecha Cara stuff I I kind of had a
recurring element of doctor and say no
who would sometimes appear in the video
and disrupting Cara's work but he wasn't
really a serious threat it was just
selling something fun to do because
Linkara is the comic book guy review
superheroes superhero versus super
villain that kind of thing
when around the time of the Superman
versus the terminator review there's a
crossover for you uh I decided you know
I want to have something to draw in
viewers I want to have a recurring
element to keep that keeps them watching
every week to see if there's advancement
of it so I decided well how about an
evil robot version of Linkara and I had
no and it's funny you compliment me
on the continuity and whatnot because
the very first two storylines I did
mostly on the fly uh uh it would go like
three or four weeks and I sided well I
should really have another storyline
thing and and I'll keep going and I'll
keep making it up as I go along and in
this case I was like okay he wants to
get the magic gun why I will figure that
out later and usually usually might like
November or October I had figured out
you know how it was going to end maybe I
hadn't written out how was gonna end yet
but I knew what direction it was heading
the backstory and whatnot and I could
write that out later so it started out
just as a way to get viewers more
invested and more interested and they
seemed to have really become invested I
recently tried to run a poll had to stop
the poll early unfortunately but got
about 2,000 responses and of that about
six only about 16% did not care for the
storylines most I mean and that's that's
pretty good numbers I would say I used
to think it was a half and half but more
people these days are watching the
storylines than not it would seem I bet
they just complain really loudly though
no not not as much anymore
I do remember a comment back in the day
uh I had gone it had been like two
months since the storyline episode
because I cuz when it sort of line ends
I take a break to plan out the next one
relax a bit so I don't have to do lots
and lots of intense filming especially
for fight scenes and whatnot and this
guy went off on a tirade about I hate
your show and I hate I do because you
have the storylines gone why do you
include all this story crap why you keep
doing this and I would remind you this
episode did not have any storyline
elements and that's and it had been two
months since I had done a storyline
episode he just brought this up write
the hell out of nowhere it's just this
does this ranty tirade against them I
don't know where they came from why they
did it but if you're gonna complain to
me about it at least do it on a video
where it's actually relevant do you find
that you're obviously very good with
your fans you respond
to allow your fans um I've seen you at
conventions where you're very strong
about no matter how long the line is we
will get through them all we will sign
everything I mean if you're very very
dedicated creatively uh how much do you
listen to your fans in terms of the
choices you make if some if a certain
amount of people don't like something do
you change it or do you trust your gut
or do you let them influence how much
influence do the fans have have on
either the review or the storyline most
of us they do have an influence but it's
mostly on the minutia it's not on the
overall direction of the storyline
except for maybe Oh Matt has a good idea
I'll write that down for lit for later
but most of the time they affect like
backstories and names for things that I
would have that I try to come up with
but they have better names for for
example dr. link say no his name was not
originally dr. link say no it was just
some other a parallel universe doctor
and say no but the fan named for him
became linked say no and the fan
backstory for him was that he was the
other schlump er brother from a review
that Spoony had done called called party
mania which featured two nerdy kids the
schlump er brother is Oscar and I can't
remember the other name and like of
Oscar and Wayne and and Wayne in that in
that video it went off and became the
doctor Insano of that universe and I
decided well okay the fans like him is
being the other schlump her brother so
doctor links a know is that schlump er
brother
and so they influenced that the name the
magic gun has the spirit of a child
inside of it and originally I didn't
have a name for her she was just the
spirit of the gun it would just be like
an ongoing thing that we didn't know her
name but there was a fan art of her that
named her Maggie because Maggie magic
gun haha and I said you know that's how
she could name it I named her Margaret
so yeah pretty much the same thing oh
yeah so baby so basically it was is they
affect and influence all the little
stuff that's not important to the grand
scheme of things so come up with some
great fan ideas that I will incorporate
later on but for a single storyline I
know where it's going I have faith in my
own
ability to make it fulfilling for them
although things will change over time I
remember the entity storyline was
originally going to end with a fight but
it's going to be me versus an eldritch
abomination God glitch entity thing so
it's one of those things where yeah I
could fight it or I would be or I could
not look like a Mary Sue and I'd be
killing this thing and no fight would be
satisfying after all the build-up so
let's try something different with that
Twitter Facebook all sorts of social
media again you very much interact with
your fans uh but again both of us have
seen people who have also gotten lost in
that and sort of let the fans decide
what their emotions will be and decide
everything uh how do you think it's what
do you think is best in finding that
balance of communicating with fans but
not letting them rule your life
necessarily either the fans in the end
really are my bosses in my opinion
anyway because without their views I
couldn't be doing what I'm doing I
couldn't there is no show if there are
no viewers and in this case as such I
feel an obligation to them to deliver a
good product and to listen to their own
feedback and their complaints and their
suggestions and I will not necessarily
always take it in to regard because I
both think in some cases
I know better than them in this case
they might think they know what they
want but I think I but I know what I
really know what they want is that it's
not meant to be pretentious it's just
meant to be I I know how this is going
to develop and I know that they're going
to ultimately be satisfied with the end
product and 99% of the time they are
there's always fringe elements who say I
didn't enjoy this as much but but for
the most part the majority try to stay
happy and the thing is the reason why I
mean aside from the fact that they are
without them I would not have a show and
the lit end means to live off of it but
I was in their place once I was a fan I
mean I was a fan of the Nostalgia Critic
before I became a video perdu
for myself and got on the same website
so I know where they are coming from I
understand where they're coming from
where they get really excited about
something and get really hyped about
something and and the love they feel
about interacting with somebody and if I
can just bring a little bit of joy into
their lives why not I'll retweet their
their own videos or their Kickstarter or
something like that if it brings them
just a little bit of joy why the heck
not
we're comics are now this very
interesting place but I don't think
they've ever had quite this connection
to with not just the social media but
that just films I mean such a big
connection now where do you see comics
going do you think this is as tall as
it's going to go for a while or do you
think it has even more room to grow the
big problem we have right now is that
while there is a connection storyline
wise with the films and whatnot uh there
are a few problems here one they're not
actually getting that many new readers
they should be trying harder to get more
readers but comic companies are slow to
move with the time bear in mind it's
taken them this long to be in a state
where where Marvel can say yeah we have
we have an x-men group that's made up
all of women where we have a book a
headlining book that we're promoting
heavily with not only a Muslim superhero
but a big-name Muslim superhero in that
regard it's taking them this long to do
that where they to them to acknowledge
that 50% of the audience is women and
50% of the readers are women and they
want to actually like start appealing to
them because they've been stuck in this
boy's club mindset for so long and they
are been slow to work on new
technologies
they've been slow to release stuff
digitally or they're afraid of
alienating comic bookstore owners
because that's that is the direct market
that is where they make their money
and in this case the future of comics is
going to be digital whether they like it
or not web comics are still big they're
still popular and in some cases they're
more they're a lot more popular
regular comics it's very rare that I see
hey did you see the sales of print
recently and paper they're going up and
up more everyday and don't get me wrong
I love printed stuff I love having
actual books and that will never stop
that will never end where people dislike
say no I don't want physical books
anymore I just want my little electronic
device that I can drop and lose
everything on it no no no that's never
going to change but the thing is they
need to be willing to embrace the new
technologies out there for digital
distribution and if that means creating
original content strictly digital so be
it and going back to that DC makes one
good decision than three bad ones a good
decision they made recently was that
they announced an all digital Wonder
Woman book with like top named talent
and I'm like yay why the hell wasn't
this here three years ago I'd like to
end every interview with the same two
polar opposite questions and the first
one is what is the toughest thing you've
ever had to go through whether it be
personal or professionally and how did
you get through it toughest thing I've
had to go
[Music]
I'm uh say uh toughest thing I've had to
do uh hearing any kind of discipline
like masks disappointment from people it
happens that I'm not very often but I do
hear disappointment from fans of a time
where I just honestly they feel I've let
them down and it makes me feel depressed
too because like I said this is I feel
they are my bosses that they are the
ones who I could not do this without
them and if I ever feel that guys see
that kind of thing I just want to be
like well is there anything I can what
can I do now in the future to do better
with that and that's really how I try to
work through these kind of thing I spot
I suppose in terms of personal life and
why not uh losing Justin was a Jew REO
was pretty hard-hitting for me my mom
likes to say that I'm pretty good at
bouncing back after bad news or
something really hits me and it's true
but it hurt
it's and there's constant reminders of
little things like that and you know
best thing I can offer is life moves on
you have and you can't just keep
focusing on it for the rest of your life
you have to be willing to move on
because there's so much more to do the
next thing around the corner and that
that's probably what helps me do with
the fact that I just the show must go on
I must get that episode out on Monday
and finally what is the proudest thing
whether it be professional or personal
that you feel you've ever done to do
anytime I get him anytime I get an email
from someone telling me you have made my
life better I was in a dark place for
this time watching your show helped me
you made me laugh on days where it
seemed like nothing could make me laugh
I always want to tell this story not a
story with it but this basic quote
because people sometimes ask me how do
you deal with all the troll eight that
that happens around you you get to get
people who say your show sucks your show
is horrible you're not funny you stretch
too much for jokes I hate everything you
do all that kind of how do you how do
you deal with that kind of stuff how do
you deal with someone telling you you'll
never be as popular as the Bee Gees
that's a real comment by the way how do
you deal with that I have a job that
allows me to be creative allows me to
work from home allows me to set my own
hours I get to work with an awesome
group of people who are smarter than me
why I'm proud to call my friends I am
dating someone beautiful and wonderful
who loves me and I love them back I have
a great apartment I have a great job I
have a great life and people tell me
that I have made their life better what
the hell is a troll going to say that's
ever going to top that
[Music]
this has been Luis Vargas has been shot
these are really funny - they're
finalized at the helm at IBM I fire you
oh yeah anything the mind of the real
islands go hey yeah yeah let's see how
funny yeah
I'm never being on the stock show yeah I
don't want you